hello everybody and welcome parts uh-oh
never mind gonna cut that out no no I'm
gonna leave it I have integrity you see
all of my mistakes welcome to part 17 of
let's play penumbra overture okay
got more cages oh I've been everywhere
and I just collected notes I got in
victory flashes after I left all these
places oh I don't have the code to
section C
I'll hold the note under that hammer it
out I don't know I think the code is on
here I think what do I do
there is no code written on it question
mark as far as you can tell but I can
tell much farther than you let's just go
back to Section C that doors locked
forever
ma-ma-ma-ma-ma cages
I would so love to have something scary
happen rather than non-stop puzzles Oh
boop beep bop Boop nope
shut up shut up John don't be so
condescending
I could brute my way a brute force my
way through anything
not just brute my way brute force
nothing up there learn to check on the
top shelves what's up here this smash
anything Hey
nope yeah alright nothing here in this
cage nothing a la nothing
nothing there oh man I'm making an ass
out of my ha shut up John you're not
witty at all I've seen that many sacks
wait no yeah no I haven't alright I
guess I'm making the fruitless loop
again let's go to shaft well that seems
good like this here anything
Oh Oh aha oh yeah okay what's in here
shut up
why do you even give me a door if all
you're gonna give me as false hope
oh I will so blow you up I will blow you
sky ha oh yeah get blown Oh F your face
oh you taught me with these
impossibilities
alright section C or shaft 12 uh okay
okay I'm okay it's alright it's alright
maybe I didn't maybe I miss maybe who
knows
the awesome super awesome cart ride down
smashed into the wall I was curious I
figured there would be something else in
here maybe I'll shut up whispers care
about you chair chair anything behind
here
oh yeah oh oh yeah oh yeah ah 1970 that
sounds like a code and Dixon was it ah
delayed explosion Oh fine fine fine fine
fine
I don't care okay their code in here
Cody code code on the wall code
microscope code in the microscope uh-huh
Oh code code code aah aah aah aah yeah
aah gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
Oh 1974 Oh 47 Oh zero one seven four
zero one four seven yeah yeah yeah
that's totally it I see that you know
that's my best guess of this entire
thing uh zero one four seven oh that's
probably not it registration code oh uh
uh registration codes of the ship and
question Oh code Joe on four seven oh
maybe oh maybe oh maybe maybe maybe
maybe oh do you have the code
it's coding there oh is it going there
please let the code be that Oh Oh quick
oh yeah oh oh creepy
Oh what do we got okay Oh code oh yeah
oh yeah
Oh Billy's maybe all right what do we
got what do we got oh yeah
God mislead both bodies no one strange
okay okay
trying code code code give me code give
me code give me a code two for slugs um
there are different levels
oh the square root of 9 is 3
Oh code zero zero one zero
no this dojo
no code damn darn it part 800 right fine
oh that's why Billy talked to me because
it was his craziness okay whatever
oh my best guess right now is zero one
four seven oh man hello shut up nope
nothing nothing at all it's a waste of
my life waste of my life Oh waste of my
life
let me try zero one four seven that's
probably not it
Oh making an ass out of myself like I
always do oh oh what's that oh oh shut
up yeah oh never mind
oh yeah swear I can't with a refinery
okay all right off it reflash why why
again I don't even think that's a
victory flash anymore that's just an
autosave or something oh let me try the
code let me try the code shut up worm I
will I will get to you eventually you
will you'll be able to eat me soon ish
Oh get ready for failure yep yep yep
bail bail bail
big fat fail Oh
going back to chef 13 I suppose oh
there's got to be something I missed
about that blank no oh it's got to be
staring me right in the face
what was that I see some nope come on
I'm smarter than this
oh hang on I got pump up my brain all
right I'm ready come on bring it bring
it on yeah you're happy Oh what did I
miss don't care don't care don't care
anything in this book that I threw away
so carelessly anything behind these
rocks said I didn't appreciate a light
switch more scribbling on the walls no
in the boot in the boot all right
there's two boots and two hats one chair
what does it mean what does it all mean
does it all mean what does it all mean
maybe right now this is a stretch
there's something in the spider tunnels
that I missed I didn't make a right turn
or something I don't know
oh it's blocked up anyway never mind oh
no it's happening it's happening oh oh I
look so stupid I'm not stupid I'm smart
I'm smart
Oh victory no save game all right I can
figure this out let me go back to the
refinery because that's the only place
that I haven't been it makes sense I get
everything from the shafts
I wouldn't think to go back to the
refinery why would I need to go there oh
we're fine I am there okay right right
oh I want a monster oh love love to have
a monster just run up and bite my face
off I love that oh no I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm not dead
well I'm gonna die here cuz obviously I
can't go anywhere else
oh come on more steam why steam high
steam oh I didn't need that for the dog
he's that beat him in their faces
nope nothing nothing nothing at all
nothing at all
I'm being the most boring youtuber in
the world nothing whatsoever oh I've
been - f12 I've been to the tool shed
there's gotta be something it's got to
be in my inventory something I am not
seeing blank piece of paper what do I do
with a piece of paper what do i do what
do i do what do i do oh oh am i dumb am
i dumb ultraviolet light ultraviolet oh
oh oh go to the room go to room oh the
room Kappa no it was chef 12 I was right
there I'll mark you so stupid all right
oh oh but you're gonna redeem yourself
all you're gonna redeem yourself you're
gonna
oh look look look at it we're gonna know
oh yeah oh yeah this is it this is it
all this is it guys
oh yeah I'll bear with me oh I'm ready
I'm ready for it
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah one
three seven one I was close I was close
one three seven one all year oh so smart
Oh smart smart smart smart except for
that time when I was dumb yeah then I
was done but now I'm smart yeah oh yeah
oh yeah yeah oh that is a victory flash
oh yeah I'm gonna have to pause it here
but you will see the fruits of my labor
in part 18 oh yeah see you then bye bye